a hulking dude won the ncaa d1 women's
swimming and diving championship over
the weekend and now
everyone is pretending to care about
women's sports and they are doing that
because it's the most socially
acceptable way to criticize
transgenderism so now people get to say
i'm not anti-trans and people should
totally be able to do whatever they want
but this is wrong because this is not
fair to girls
true it is not fair to girls
but that is not the point
the problem with transgenderism is not
that it makes it complicated to
engage in college swim meets the problem
with transgenderism is that it's a false
account of human nature that encourages
delusion psychosis and self-mutilation
that's the problem
people are making this issue way more
complicated than it actually is either
the transgender belief that men can
secretly be women and vice versa is
correct
or it isn't
obviously
it isn't
so then why are we restructuring our law
and our politics and our culture
according to a premise that every single
sensible person in the entire world
knows is absurd
there's an answer it's not just a
hypothetical question i actually think i
know the answer the answer has to do
with our national obsession with
openness and permissiveness it has to do
with our confusing liberty
with licentiousness licentiousness just
the
fulfillment of any appetite that you've
got this is a confusion that our
founding fathers like many other wise
men throughout history warned us would
completely sink our republic we want to
be open to everything we want to
tolerate everything we want to be really
nice we don't want to be close-minded
that's the worst thing you can be
illiberal that's the worst thing you can
possibly be and so a lot of people want
to split the baby on transgenderism
by encouraging it in some circumstances
but not in others and the way that they
do this is by using the language of
individualism they'll say
listen here if a man wants to wear a
dress and call himself sally well by
golly that's his right that's none of my
business so i have no right to infringe
on that but
he can't infringe on my rights or the
rights of those girls who are swimming
this strategy has never worked and it
will never work because the man's
alleged right to pretend to be a woman
necessarily infringes on our right in
society to treat men as men and women as
women
we live in a society these
rights quote unquote rights affect real
rights that we've all got the man's
quote unquote right to pretend to be a
woman infringes on women's right to have
their own bathrooms infringes on our
right to call people by their correct
pronouns
infringes on the girl swimmer's right to
compete against women in the ncaa
championship
there is only one way
to stop transgenderism
that is to oppose it
entirely the whole thing
for young people for old people
on this continent on another the whole
thing there is no
natural
or constitutional
or civil right to fantasy
and there is nothing compassionate about
encouraging disturbed people to indulge
their destructive delusions
yes it's unfair that transgender
ideology permitted william leah thomas
to take a trophy away from a young woman
at a swimming competition
but it's unfair because it's unjust and
it's unjust because it's based on a lie
if you recognize that something is wrong
with this picture then stop pussyfooting
around the issue the only way to stop
this madness is to stop tolerating the
ideology of transgenderism in all times
in all places full stop a picture
tells a thousand words
and that picture of william thomas who
goes by the name leah
standing on the podium with his
championship prize
and then you've got number two and
number three there was another photo
where it's just the actual girls sort of
crowding around taking a photo of one
two three
william thomas completely on the side it
tells you everything you need to know
there was another photo of thomas
wearing his
women's swimming suit
and uh
lots of things were clear from that
photo okay a lot lots of philosophical
things anatomical things it was just
preposterous and will thomas at the
women's swimming competition gave an
interview afterward to say what this
meant to him
i can't tell you how free i feel now
that i've started identifying as a woman
now that i can compete as female i'm
ready to smash the other girls
and is it correct you just started
identifying as female two weeks ago i'm
not here to talk about my transition i'm
here to kick some
ass
let me tell you something dingleberry
david perry i'm gonna roll up the other
women here and i'm gonna smoke them
i am the strongest woman this state has
ever
seen sorry that was a clip from south
park which predicted this exact thing
that would happen and back then it was a
joke and it was it was satire and now
it's become reality because satire is
completely dead here is the clip of
actual will thomas at the women's
swimming competition
you've undoubtedly been under the
spotlight over the past few months how
have you been dealing with that and
reasoning with everything
i try to ignore it as much as i can
i try to focus on my swimming
uh what i need to do to get ready for my
races
and just try to block out everything
else
i just try to block out everything else
like reality that's what he's blocking
out what's amazing about the clip is and
you're lucky that you didn't have to see
the lower half
it
it's obvious that he's a man in in some
cases with transgenderism there are
enough perverts in the scientific
community that they'll poke and prod and
shoot you full of hormones and chop
things off and and give you cosmetic
surgery that it's not always totally 100
clear
if a person is a man or a woman
because of all the crazy interventions
that people have now but in this case
it's just totally clear he's a dude he's
a hulking dude with super broad
shoulders with all of his anatomical
features that he has had since the day
he was born with a relatively deep voice
just talking like a guy the only thing
that he sort of did
was grow his hair out a little bit and
then put it in a swimming cap anyway
there is no
question here that he's a guy and so
they say well what do you make of the
criticism that you're cheating these
girls out of their trophies
what do you make of the criticism that
this is wrong and unfair and unjust and
he says i just block it out and that's
all we're doing and this is not just a
will thomas problem this is not just a
girl's collegiate swimming problem this
is a society problem is that when
deluded people in this society
come across a fact that they don't like
they not only want to block it out but
increasingly they can block it out
because we're so isolated now the the
structures of community that used to
keep us somewhat tethered to reality the
family the civil society the government
for that matter they've broken those
tethers and so now you can go you can
sit on your phone scroll all day long go
into ever more fantastical delusional
communities and be affirmed in your
crazy incorrect beliefs then you can go
to your various affinity groups and gain
political power and then force this
stuff to
try to manipulate reality so you go and
you say look there's a whole group of us
who we're convinced now that men are
actually women and so we're going to
completely change women's sports and the
craziest part is because our society
doesn't have anything to stand on
anymore because we've rejected
theology and philosophy and even the
existence of objective truth this the
coaches and the administrators and the
schools go along with this crap and the
government goes along with it too and
now guarantees it what do you do when
you hear criticism well i just block it
out of course you block it out and i'm
not necessarily criticizing will thomas
i actually have this
i don't think it's likely but i do have
this strange thought i thought
what if
this guy's just a performance artist
what if this guy is doing a super
deep
performance where he's showing the
absurdity of transgenderism because he's
a hulking dude he beats all the women in
the swimming matches he tunes out the
criticism he exposes society for being
completely incoherent on this issue and
then at the end of his college career he
gets out he's like guys what are you
what were you thinking i'm obviously a
man why would you give me the women's
trophy this is wrong look at you look at
what's become of you i don't think
that's likely but it certainly could be
for for everything that we know about
this
let's say that he is sincere let's say
that he really does think that he's a
woman that should be a cause for our
compassion and empathy and pity and we
should try to convince him of reality
instead of telling a disturbed
individual that all of his delusions are
real and encouraging him down a path
that is destructive not only for himself
not only for those girls who didn't get
their trophy because he was beating them
because he's a dude but for all of
society as well
you know what's really destructive to
your time and money
driving to the brick and mortar auto
parts store that's why you gotta go to
rockauto.com
go to rock auto today
this whole show is going to be taken
offline today right
there's no question this is good it's
going to be taken offline because this
it's called hateful conduct
it it's it's violating twitter's and
youtube's and facebook's rules
if you state basic truths now
at the very least we're told we have to
couch these basic truths so you've got
to
you can't call a man who thinks he's a
woman a man you've got to say well he's
a biological man
as though there were some other kind of
man
[Music]